[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
je trouve qu'il y a pas plus attirant
qu'un homme qui arbore la quarantaine tu
vois c'est le moment en fait il
m'empêche parce que pourquoi parce qu'en
fait il prend confiance en lui un homme
ça prend beaucoup plus de temps qu'une
femme parce qu'il a installé parce que
ça y est il a réussi à avoir une
stabilité de vie parce qu'il se sent à
l'aise dans son métier qu'il a pu
effectivement prendre un peu plus
peut-être de les monter en tout cas en
échelle dans son métier je disais
qu'aujourd'hui il est plus à l'aise tu
as 25 ans tu pourrais sortir avec un mec
de 50 ans
je pourrais aller jusqu'à un bon 45 47
ouais facile ouais
si tu pouvais vivre dans n'importe
quelle époque là maintenant tu
choisirais laquelle
pour les femmes je pense qu'en tant que
femme à une autre époque
ou alors à la préhistoire et essayer de
de lancer les bonnes bases de mettre des
bases un petit peu différente